there's always the thing you're longing
for
and the sadness has to do with the
getting a glimpse of it but not quite
getting a hold of it
yeah yeah so there's always losing it's
always losing but it's also always that
but it's not that sounds really
depressing but it's
it's not you know it's not depressing
because you experience this all the time
it's also
those are the most beautiful moments i
think
life offers i mean it's intense intense
beauty in those moments
because it's getting closer to the real
thing that we long for
so what about
like loss
losing love
is that
also
a beautiful thing
well
the moments you're talking about
i think it's easier to appreciate the
beauty of it all in
the moment because you're experiencing
[Music]
you're kind of experiencing the loss and
the love all at the same time
um whereas if you're talking about
straight-up loss like a betrayal or a
bereavement or whatever it is
that's
it's different it's quite overwhelming
um so losing loved one kind of thing
losing a loved one i mean i i will say
that
the truth that i think that we can come
to after
a lot of time on this earth is the idea
that
love exists not only in its particular
forms so not only in the form of
the one person
you know that one person we love or that
other person we love but love itself is
a state that we have access to
and so over time
the
the loss of person a can heal and you
can tap into
a kind of bigger river of love yeah i
mean i had this this comes from louis
louis ck uh i got a show
damn i love that line i mean there's uh
he's talked to an older gentleman
and uh louise
is all like
sad about um
losing a loved one or like getting
rejected essentially like a breakup
and then the the older gentleman
gives him advice saying like
uh what basically criticizes louis for
saying why are you moping around because
this is the most this is the best part
like losing love is the best part
because it that's
the real loss is when you forget
uh like feeling shitty about having gone
through a breakup
is when you most intensely appreciate
what that person meant to you
like you most intensely feel love in
some
strange way by realizing that you've
lost it by missing it wishing at this
moment i wish i had that
like that feeling
that that's when you feel that love the
most the absence of it and so
the the older gentleman gives advice
that that that's the best part and it
can if you're good with it it can last
for the longest
it could be the most uh sort of
prolonged experience of deep
appreciation and emotion and so on so
that that's kind of a
that's a nice way to look at loss
which is a reminder of how much somebody
meant to us yeah i mean i think there's
a lot of truth in that um
because
yeah you wouldn't care so much if it
weren't something that mattered to you
so it's always a signpost to the
direction you really want to go to
that's always what it is
um
yeah and it's interesting to see the way
that
the mystical
versions of
many of the great religions all point in
this direction you know whether you're
looking at sufism or
or the kabbalah or in christian
mysticism you see this idea that
the longing for what you lack
is the very thing that gives you what
you're longing for
so the longing is the cure i mean that's
the way
the sufi poet rumi puts it the longing
is the cure um you know and he says be
thirsty like be as thirsty as you
possibly can
that's what you want to be
the good stuff is the wanting not the
having
yeah yeah of course tell it to a person
i just broke up and they'll be like shut
up [ __ ]
advice sucks i wish i had i had her him
back
yeah no absolutely i
those are the kinds of life lessons that
only work when you kind of step away for
a while they don't work in the moment
in the moment of excruciation
there is something about the fact of
knowing that all humans are in that
experience together
that is also incredibly uplifting
well that takes time for people to
realize
like um
you know like heartbreak
in your early teenage years or something
like that could feel like this is the
completely the most novel yes and the
most dramatic
uh
pain that any human has ever felt
right or maybe even when you're younger
and then one of the process one of the
things you realize
is that everybody goes through this
that can be an awakening to the fact
that we're all in this together this
human condition is not just a personal
experience it's an experience we all
share and that's uh that's a kind of
love the unity of it yeah you can get to
experience really a deep kind of love
and i feel like you know we're
we are prevented from perceiving that
love as
it's actually like the most obvious kind
of love and it's right there and it
happens all the time but we're prevented
from perceiving it because we're not
really supposed to talk about things
like that it's like there's something
unseemly about it well it's also in the
west is this individualist society so
like
there's a pressure to sort of
see the individual as a distinct
sovereign entity
that um experiences things and it's not
the unity between people is not it's not
obviously sort of communicated or talked
about or is part of the culture
you